the next step is alignment now a lot of
it's probably not that interesting to
you it's more interesting to me as a
teacher okay because I'm like oh you
guys got you know say my mean for my
class just my need this year and last
year it was 85 okay
so for me as a teacher it helps me to be
able to understand the difference
between you you're probably not so
interested because you're only comparing
ourselves with the people who you're
going through it because they're the
people who you're fighting for to get
into courses and so on okay so this is
more for a teacher but it's still
important okay because before actually
three 2001 so not that it's relevant to
you but we have always called norms
based assessment well what that means is
after this process of moderation they
take an average the Board of Studies
stops okay now someone might land on say
95 but that 95 has learn has no meaning
really guide to 95 in a different year
okay because it's like well if all of
you guys are smart you might all get 95
and another year if with if they're all
really poor they might also all get 95
because that's the way the moderation
works okay
so what they do is instead of going
north post assessment they have what's
called standards-based so here's what it
looks like okay suppose we have all of
your scores and they're all in a big
sort of table you have people who score
like 99
ninety-eight and so on all the way down
and then you've got someone who scored
50 down here okay now here's the
question I want you answer this number
here which I've gotten from this process
okay what kind of skill level does it
actually represent right so there's a
group of people that border studies in
their Court judges big fancy name and
they're super experienced and they
understand the courses and their
outcomes and the standard of what a
student should be like and they
understand it really well okay
so what they'll do is they'll look at
say what's the top number of people who
should be and this is languages familiar
to you it should be say a band six okay
and when you go into each courses
syllabus then a band six students should
be able to you know do sophisticated
language and blah blah blah blah blah
and it's meant to be objective for every
year okay so it's like okay look in 2013
we had this number of people who could
demonstrate band six competence okay but
maybe the person who was down here who
was the the weakest person who still met
these requirements okay maybe they
scored 17 okay so you've got 72 71 80
etc all the way up to 99 okay but that's
not bad six according to the marks at
you know right band six should be 90 and
above right that's what happens is these
get aligned to these scores okay which
obviously means these guys are gonna get
very tightly bunched together okay but
if they all can meet band six right like
if you have a large or really smart
grade okay if they can meet that they
should get ninety to a hundred because
that's what band six means and then you
know maybe the next group you know these
are the people who can do band five so
they'll get scores between 80 and 90 and
so on okay so this is the process of
alignment and it can work the other way
as well suppose people from 99 to 70 you
look at their bands and you're like wait
none of them have been Sikhs this is a
really dumb year these these guys are
actually banned for right so that would
mean I can talk the talk person right
because it's
something in the water who knows okay
that person should get what they're for
would be a me right the top mark would
be eighty okay so that's the process of
alignment so I can say look this year
versus that year this is how they're
really performing so now you know if
you've got like a brother or sister who
went through before you right and they
got say in ninety and you get ninety one
you are now justified it saying I'm
smarter than you okay or if it goes the
other way then they're justified in
saying this model you because now the
numbers really mean something they've
been they've been aligned in such a way
to these objective standards so that
people would say yeah you know a ninety
really means this kind of level of
performance or a 95 all right
does that make sense yes right let's do
the last one I need some more space
which is scary like I said this is what
people usually think of when they think
of wrong you're the black boxes what
happens to your marks before you end up
in a bed time okay so before I explain
it let me pose the problem to you if
you're trying to compare multiple
different things and they really are
different okay um how can you compare
them fairly so something I always
wondered I don't know why I just just
curious I guess is you know there's a
lot of sport like say you know cricket
what else golf okay
what's the common thing between all of
these sports they've all involved the
hitting of a small spherical object with
basically a glorified stick okay so and
the years that we think that okay all of
the balls are different the different in
size and material and so on and all of
the sticks are different they're all
weird shapes different lengths different
materials and so on okay so what if we
were trying to compare them and say well
which one is the is the hardest sport
okay well what would you do one way you
could go about this is say look let's
take all of you guys
and make you do some kind of objective
test right now if I'm trying to think
about you know which one is is is the
hardest okay I might say maybe weight
lifting
let's do weight lifting as an objective
test because that should test your
strength in a sort of I've got a mess
number it's a numerical sort of easy to
measure and compare okay
so I make you do I make all of you do
the tests okay
and maybe it turns out okay but you know
cricketers cuz you know that's fairly
awesome right cricketers consistently
get the best weightlifting scores so in
this objective test right versus I don't
know probably probably golfers I guess
because okay we might then conclude but
crickets the hardest sport cuz they're
the strongest and Dolf is the easiest
but you can only see the problem with
that right what's the problem but why is
it hard is that is the important thing
back it's hard in a different way right
so you know the golfers they lose and
after the results of Hamish they're like
this is ridiculous it's not about just
you know raw raw strength it should be
about accuracy
you know you cricketers you just have to
hit it this far Golf is like I can't
even see where I'm hitting it right and
this is tiny being so accuracy should
really be the objective tests that we
use right and then you know the tennis
players might disagree they're like no
no no it's not about strength or
actually it's about timing
if you don't play tennis properly right
it's all about like the difference
between hitting a ball well and medium
poorly it's like a split second you hit
it if you swing too early you're just
missed if you swing too late it's just
gonna go you know skyrocketing into the
air so everyone's gonna disagree about
what this other test should be does that
make sense so this is a problem okay now
there's another way to do it actually as
many ways but he's a better way to do it
okay what you can do is you could get
all these people from these five sports
right and then
put on the comedy channel or something
like that make them all play each
other's sports okay you see what this is
going to do they might all start playing
each other sports and then it's just it
comes out but um maybe it is the tennis
players okay
they consistently beat everyone at other
sports okay but you know the tennis
players are better at cricket
then the golfers all the Hodgman players
all the baseballs and so on okay
obviously you'd expect the frequency mr.
cricket but you can compare the rest
right so if the tennis players can be
everyone at the other sports and suppose
you know unfortunately again the golfers
they turn out to be terribly copy
they're not go to creative they're not
gonna hockey and so on okay then you
might say well that's the measure I'm
gonna use tennis is clearly the hardest
sport because they're better at everyone
else's sports okay so this is what you
act as with regard to his subjects it
says sports right so let me try and give
you a simple example one of the most
common subjects English is kind of
military right let's go further let's go
further maths chemistry is pretty
popular
yeah okay now suppose you've got two
students okay let's call them I don't
know say say anyway and let's see what
marks they get for each of the subjects
okay now before I put them down let's
suppose there's a there's a fourth
subject okay there's an other subject
which they don't have in common and I'm
trying to determine which subject of
these is harder and I should keep more
waiting to okay so suppose you know
pseudo crew gets introduced as a um as
an HSE subject right and target do you
have target is that's the one where
there's armpits a grid three by three
and there are nine letters okay and
you've got to go like I don't know
something like something like this so
there's this number one there's a my
letter word that exists that uses all
the letters
and then secondly you have to think of
as many words as you can of any length
but they all have to have the middle
that hits target okay so it's like how
many can you get right now suppose
suppose in the final Sudoku exam and
final target exam both of them score 95
here's my problem
I don't know what the 95s mean is target
really hard and pseudo key really easy
or are they about the same how do I
judge right so what I'll do is I'll look
at all the other sports this makes sense
okay sir suppose Chelsea just blows
everything away right you know she gets
up she gets really great marks across
all their other subjects Daniel
unfortunately has a bad day or a bad
deal or something right and he just he
just really he's like I tried okay but
that's how he does now what would you
conclude okay one conclusion you could
draw is that well look they both got 95
right but this student clearly is has
got brains right whereas this one not
the sharpest tool in the shed and yet
still scored 95 in this subject right so
one conclusion you could draw on it
this can't be that hard like how hard it
is to get 95 you know if a student of
this caliber can get 95 then you know it
can't be that hard right so I would
judge target as an easier subject Sudoku
is harder and I as a board which is sort
of interested in put together an overall
ranking I would wait this less okay now
to be fair that's not the only plausible
explanation for why this is okay maybe
it's just that Daniels talents just
don't lie and these you know these
mainstream subjects he's you know he's a
hipster of um the HSC so he's just a
prodigy at target and he really is smart
and it really is a hard subject he's
just also matter okay now that is a
plausible explanation but as an
explanation for hundreds or thousands of
students that starts to become less
valid right because if you've got
hundreds and thousands
student and they're consistently doing
poorly but doing well in this subject it
looks more likely that you know it's not
just gonna be v6 object it's gonna be a
whole range it's gonna be you know
dozens of sports that wow these guys are
really bad right so when you've got a
large candidature then the judgment that
I just made based on how they do in
other subjects starts to become more
reliable okay so what will happen is
this ninety five might get scaled to a
ninety five
whereas this ninety five might get
scaled to a semi okay and then that gets
added up the ten best units when you get
a mark out of five hundred they could
forget
and then they produce something out of
it which of course I'm not gonna deal
with rankings at all because that's even
read are and it's like why should the
person who comes first what should we
call they ranking I know let's call it
99.95 because that sounds like first to
me that's weird I don't know why they've
done levels like that but I guess people
associate big numbers with good big
equals good so that's how moderation
illuminance scaling basically works and
these are quite complicated when you
think about the problems that have to be
dealt with it's quite clever right like
though who thought these things up it's
well actually a lot of people but um
yeah a lot of wisdom and insight went
into this process okay so I think if
there's one takeaway from all of this
apart from just keep working hard right
um it's mainly from this one which is
that if the water space does take into
account how good your school is as a
whole and then as an individual basis
your performance on that fifty percent
okay
it's in your interest to have your
entire school be really really strong
okay so in the weeks to come
I hope you guys work really well
together you know you've got two weeks I
don't know about you but when I'm alone
my threshold for I don't feel like
working so therefore I will you know eat
sleep YouTube whatever right
my threshold is really low when I buy
myself whereas when I mean
with other people and they're all you
know writing I get up and then so on you
know one or many people will set your
ass down and get back to your paper okay
so work together right and the stronger
house school is the walk the better
everyone will perform